a court in hong kong has sentenced
pro-democracy activists for planning and
participating in a 2020 vigil marking
the tiananmen square massacre the
high-profile activists include media
mogul jimmy lai and li chokyan who for
years helped organize the annual event
they were among thousands of people who
gathered in victoria park but the vigil
was banned in 2020 with authorities
saying it violated coronavirus rules but
critics say it was more to do with the
crackdown on dissent in hong kong
i'm joined now by our correspondent
phoebe kong who's standing by phoebe
what more can you tell us about the
sentences that have been handed down
here
well today there were uh there are eight
defendants uh sentenced at court today
for the roles in the banned tenement
vigil last year in 2020 at the fair
iconic memorial site at victoria park
and the court handed down
4.5 to 14 months jail term to the eight
defendants
among them were like include the most
prominent figures in hong kong like jimi
lai the media tycoon and also they are
hong kong alliances uh chairman leech
again and the vice chairman ciao hang
tons so the hong kong alliance was the
visual organizer for over three decades
before the visual was first banned in
2020 so it was also a leading activist
group and uh
other than the rest of them are former
lawmakers and also activists so hey they
have to serve jail terms for uh 4.5 to
14 months um in the present and and that
was like among the one of the most
heavier sentence in the same in the
similar cases because like earlier this
year and last year we saw like other
defendants including joshua wong
sentence for the same incident for like
no more than 10 months so this is pretty
much
the most heaviest
the heaviest sentence that we've seen
regarding the tenement visual in hong
kong
now phoebe the court says this gathering
in 2020 violated kovid 19 restrictions
but talk to us about the crackdown and
dissent in hong kong that plays a big
role here
so last year it was the very first time
in hong kong's history that the
authorities rejected the application for
organizing um attendance official which
was basically a long tradition in hong
kong's protest history and in the civil
society that right after 1989 10 month
crackdown in beijing that every single
year in hong kong there was a massive
uh
visual and commemoration the morning the
victims killed in the uh very bloody
deadly crackdown in beijing 1989. so
last year the authorities uses the the
the reasons of like coronavir
coronavirus restrictions and the social
distancing rules to ban
the visual so um so basically the court
is ruling that these defendants they
were participating in the unauthorized
assembly which was not approved by the
police so um it was like of course the
authorities denied the accusation that
this was a political prosecution but um
during the trial we've seen defendants
argue that this is something to crush on
the freedoms and civil liberties that
guaranteed in hong kong's basic law
demanding constitution
dw correspondent phoebe kong reporting
live for us from hong kong thank you
phoebe
you